but not to be outdone folks as i
mentioned florida trying to give in to
trump's crazy demands too
and our trump-loving governor ron
desantis over here in florida
is asking the state legislature to give
him
5.2 million dollars
so that he can create
an office of election crime and security
next year
now he is urging the state legislature
to give him this new office
when they resume their session next year
obviously it's not going to happen in
2021 unfortunately for him
but again trump has demanded that we do
some audits here in florida only of the
areas biden won the five counties biden
one in south florida the big ones
um and ron de santa says sure
let me go talk to the legislature i just
got to get about five million dollars
i got to hire roughly 50 people
so you know it's going to be good it's
going to be a job creating thing right
we're going to have a new florida agency
49 permanent staffers
whose sole focus is going to be
looking into voter fraud
yeah i imagine there's going to be some
down time at that office
so hey if you're in the state of florida
looking for a job where you don't really
have to do much
maybe wait and see if this new office
gets created because that would be the
job for you
because the problem we have here is that
actually there is voter fraud in florida
we found three cases just last week it
was revealed
all three of them from the retirement
community called the villages
and all three of them
republicans
see
this is why
trump and desantis and abbott over in
texas this is why you all got to be
careful what you wish for
the vast majority of the voter fraud
cases that have been found from the 2020
election have been republicans voting
twice
obviously some of the more notable cases
we have the man who voted for his
deceased mother
used her ballot voted for trump
man who voted for his deceased wife used
her ballot to vote for trump the three
people down in the villages that it was
revealed last week they voted here in
the state of florida they also voted
absentee from other states
it didn't say who they voted for but
they're all registered republicans so we
don't have to
really even use our imaginations to
wonder how those votes went
and according to new reports they think
there's even more
voter fraud that took place in the
villages which is predominantly
republican
so ron desantis i'm gonna tell you this
man i am actually okay with you creating
this division i truly am
because voter fraud does need to be
addressed if it exists
and if you want to devote time and
resources to it then dang it you better
find some voter fraud here in the state
of florida
and according to the reports according
to an ongoing investigation apparently
the first place you need to go are those
retirement communities where it is
predominantly republicans
because that seems to be where the fraud
is running rampant
much like the other
things that have been running rampant in
the villages if you
don't know what i'm getting at i suggest
you google it
it is at one point at least one of the
highest rates of stds in the country but
when they're not doing that apparently
some of them are committing voter fraud
as well
and that's what we're dealing with here
in the state of florida
but let's not pretend for a second that
voter fraud is actually a real problem
that we need to be devoting millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours
towards fixing
are there cases out there heck yeah we
found plenty this year i mean we found a
couple handful of them let's be real
most of them are republican
so
if you all want to root it out
if you want to put your own people in
jail fine by me
i'm not going to stop you
but if you want to pretend that our
elections are somehow unsafe
because of all the fraud
that's where i draw the line because the
evidence
tells us otherwise i'm farron cousins
you can get me on twitter facebook
instagram fair and balance youtube.com
the ring of fire
rofpodcast.com we'll be right back with
more
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video